the hobbit is one of the most beloved
children stories of all time but even
grown-ups might have a few questions
left unanswered why controls talk who is
bayern and why do the eagles always save
the day keep watching to find out one of
the strangest things about the hobbit is
the way that it presents dwarves and
elves the dwarves are seen as bumbling
yet tragic heroes trying desperately to
overcome impossible odds to recover
their home sure they're willing to send
a hobbit in to do the dirty work but
overall thorin and company are a fairly
civil lot in comparison many of the
stories encounters with the elves tend
to portray them as anything but friendly
what is this horrid creature
a goblin mutant that's my we learned
gimbly
in the lord of the rings many of these
opinions are reversed dwarves are seen
as decent enough but elves are shown in
a very positive light indeed the author
is the same in both cases so what gives
did tolkien change his mind about the
two races between books while tolkien's
world was always evolving the answer has
more to do with perspective than
outright change each of tolkien's books
is very deliberately written in a
certain way in fact at the end of the
lord of the rings frodo gives the
so-called red book of west march to sam
which contains two stories the lord of
the rings and there and back again the
latter written by bilbo baggins is
essentially the story of the hobbit
bilbo's perspective of dwarves came from
an experience in which he certainly
noticed their flaws but one that was
also steeped in their own cultural and
political viewpoints frodo had some
interactions with dwarves but definitely
venerated the elves whom he interacted
with often and so the two hobbits
perspectives shine through in each of
their stories
compared to the lord of the rings the
hobbit is a very light-hearted story in
fact it's generally pretty silly goofy
and totally family-friendly in contrast
the lord of the rings is a serious sad
and adult story with many themes that
are far too intense for children so why
the difference well tolkien himself has
the answer to this in a letter to his
publisher he wrote the generally
different tone and style of the hobbit
is due and point of genesis to it being
taken by me as a matter from the great
cycle susceptible of treatment as a
fairy story for children in another
letter written to a friend tolkien
addresses the subject of tone yet again
by saying that the hobbit was unhappily
really meant as far as i was conscious
as a children's story it has some of the
silliness of manner caught unthinkingly
from the kind of stuff i had had served
to me i deeply regret them so do
intelligent children the distinct
difference in tone between each story is
very real and even the author was aware
of the change to the point that he
outright regretted it
when tolkien went to write a sequel to
the hobbit he settled on the one ring as
the connection point between the two
stories this led to a lot of subsequent
character development and a few
adjustments to the original story for
example the mysterious necromancer
character from the hobbit was chosen to
play a much bigger role in the new story
of course that character is sauron but
what is he doing in mirkwood in a
ghostly non-physical form during the
events of the hobbit the answer lies in
tolkien's personal obsession with world
building by the time the hobbit was
published the author had already been
working on what would eventually become
the silmarillion for two previous
decades in fact and when he actually sat
down to write the hobbit he found that
his then private silmarillion world
began to encroach on the story of bilbo
baggins in one letter tolkien says that
mr baggins began as a comic tale among
conventional and inconsistent grimm's
fairy tale dwarves and got drawn into
the edge of it so that even sauron the
terrible peeped over the edge trolls are
a fascinating aspect of middle earth's
history in a letter written 17 years
after the release of the hobbit tolkien
addresses the troll conundrum saying
simply i'm not sure about trolls there
are many different versions of these
underdeveloped creatures found in
tolkien's work from hill trolls to cave
trolls to oleg hai the fierce breed of
orc-like trolls that appear in the
appendix to the return of the king the
appendices also suggest that very few of
these trolls actually speak stating in
their beginning these creatures were of
dull and lumpish nature and had no more
language than beasts but sauron had made
use of them teaching them what little
they could learn and increasing their
wits with wickedness in that
aforementioned letter tolkien breaks
down the idea that trolls are likely
only counterfeits essentially that they
were made in mockery of the ants tolkien
subsequently explains that while trolls
may be able to talk they are generally
animalistic in nature but where do the
trolls from the hobbit fit into all this
they have very english names they live a
somewhat civil lifestyle and they can
easily talk
an oversized squibble i'm a burger ah
pop it out
there
well it turns out that the only trolls
who are mentioned in the appendices as
being particularly articulate are the
stone trolls who apparently spoke a
debased form of the common speech even
then this is another area in which
tolkien's opinions changed a lot over
time and yes unfortunately that means
there's no solid answer to this one
giants are rare and mystical creatures
even for middle earth they're mentioned
throughout the lord of the rings but
only in passing in the return of the
king ministereth is described as looking
as if it had been built by giants out of
the stones of the earth in the hobbit
they're brought up as creatures in many
of gandalf's stories and bilbo thinks of
them as a potential answer during his
riddle game with gollum and then of
course there's that time when bilbo
gandalf and the dwarves travel over the
misty mountains and see some real stone
giants during a thunderstorm the stone
giants cause a considerable ruckus
laughing and throwing rocks at each
other and then proceed to never be a
viable presence in anything else that
tolkien ever writes this one's tough
since tolkien himself seems to have done
a 180 on giants in this world indeed
there are many other fairly
well-developed forms of giants to be
found in the earlier versions of
tolkien's mythos but over time the
author appears to have toned down his
interest in that race to the point where
they don't feature heavily in any of his
other works
gollum is an odd one he lives alone
obsesses over his ring and loves to
snack on any living thing that happens
to wander near his home so why when
bilbo shows up is gollum's first thought
to start a game of riddles with his new
those acquaintances process doesn't like
arms doesn't
does a lot to plow
well first off dildo has a sword and
when gollum sees sting he makes sure to
be very polite until he figures out just
who this little hobbit is at least but
that still leaves another question why
riddles why wouldn't he just chat with
bilbo or stalk him or even sit there and
watch him it turns out that tolkien
answers this one via a quick easy to
miss line in the hobbit just before the
game begins the book reads riddles were
all gollum could think of asking them
and sometimes guessing them had been the
only game he had ever played with other
funny creatures sitting in their holes
in the long long ago this isn't just a
random interest either as riddles are
clearly taken very seriously in
middle-earth after the game it becomes
clear that bilbo knows that the riddle
game is sacred to many and that even
someone like gollum would be afraid to
cheat at one in other words riddles
aren't just a passing fancy for the
peoples of middle earth they're a very
serious matter indeed
the hobbit is full of incredible beasts
and creatures and one of the most
remarkable of all is bjorn the skin
changer in the hobbit novel it's implied
that there are many other bear to human
creatures like him too so what's the
origin of this strange group and where
do shape-shifters fit into tolkien's
world unfortunately this is another area
in which the author left little more
than hints and riddles as far as the
ability to change shapes goes that's
nothing new in middle earth the angelic
valar and mayar take on physical forms
all the time and in the fellowship of
the ring gandalf describes radagast as
quote a master of shapes and changes of
hue even sauron turns into a werewolf a
serpent and a vampire bat in the
silmarillion but for all that shifting
and changing bayorn's specific race of
skin changers remains highly mysterious
all we get is gandalf's initial
description of the fellow and the hobbit
which reads some say that he is a bear
descendant from the great and ancient
bears of the mountains that lived there
before the giants came others say that
he is a man descended from the first men
who lived before smaug or the other
dragons came into this part of the world
and before the goblins came into the
hills out of the north while gandalf
isn't sure himself he apparently favors
the second option but as he himself also
says about the matter i cannot tell you
much more though that ought to be enough
if you've read the hobbit and the lord
of the rings you might be wondering how
far the seven dwarven rings are involved
with bilbo's adventures after all the
hobbit features the arkenstone which is
a super jewel with its own inner power
the silmarillion also explains that the
foundation of each of the seven hordes
of the dwarf kings of old was a golden
ring but all those hordes long ago were
plundered and the dragons devoured them
it would seem natural then to suggest
that the lonely mountain might have been
home to one of those hordes so is there
a dwarven ring lying at the heart of the
mountain or possibly in smaug's belly as
it turns out no but kind of see the
lonely mountain is originally founded by
some of the dispossessed dwarves who are
driven out of moria by the balrok long
before that point one of their kings
receives one of the seven dwarven rings
and it stays in the family until
thorin's father loses it when he's
captured by the necromancer so while
there isn't a dwarven ring present in
erebor when bilbo arrives on the scene
one of the rings of power is likely
responsible for the mass of gold and
treasure on which maug sleeps
you've probably noticed that eagles play
an important role in tolkien's world
they say bilbo gandalf and the dwarves
from the clutches of the orcs of the
misty mountains they show up to help
turn the tide during the battle of the
five armies their leader gwyhere the
windlord saves gandalf when he's trapped
on orthak and his eagles swoop in to
join in the battle at the black gate of
mordor too eagles also saved the day
multiple times during the silmarillion
so what's up with the eagles always
arriving in the nick of time is it a
cop-out or a lazy excuse to resolve a
story
nope tolkien's use of the eagles to
provide dramatic savior-like moments is
something that he developed specifically
and intentionally in fact he coined a
term for this plot device a eu
catastrophe in tolkien's famous essay on
fairy stories the author points out that
while drama and tragedy go hand in hand
fairy stories must come with a
consolation or happy ending in a letter
written to his son christopher the
author defines the concept of a eu
catastrophe as the sudden happy turn in
a story which pierces you with the joy
that brings tears which i argued is the
highest function of fairy stories to
produce when writing fantasy tolkien
felt that the story must provide these
moments of grace and salvation and the
majestic eagles remained one of his
favorite ways of doing so
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]